I know I this time I really do know I
know why you're excited Hickenlooper is
in Hickenlooper John yeah the government
a former governor Colorado now there are
13 people on the Democratic side running
for president and Hickenlooper hey
Colorado when he was governor when they
became the first state in this country
to legalize marijuana so he he says he's
a long shot but he's ahead in the polls
among white guys will call each other
brah and on the other side of the ledger
Hillary made it official this week will
not run in 2020 she but she said she
will keep speaking out and will be heard
assuming you can afford her feet
but there's a little pillow reason out a
little bittersweet because today it's
international Woman's Day Trump marked
the occasion by laying a wreath on the
unknown first wife it was touching oh
you know who else is you know who else
is out bill shine he is Trump's fifth
he's had five communications director
this guy used to run Fox News apparently
he can't get along with Trump either so
bill shiny is gonna be moving over to a
Trump's campaign re-election
headquarters so he's moving to Moscow
and of course you heard the big news
from former campaign manager Paul
Manafort was sentenced to four years in
jail and I don't know if he has I thank
you I don't know if Matt affort has
learned his lesson his first question
was a does the jumpsuit come in ostrich
yeah he got it pretty easy the
Sentencing Guidelines said he was
supposed to get 19 to 24 years he got
four otherwise known as the white guy
discount yeah I haven't seen a trump
supporter get off that much since Robert
Kraft went to that massage parlor
but the judge was in the tank for Trump
to begin with we saw this right he said
mana fort lived an otherwise blameless
life what a mana forts company was known
as the torturers Lobby they worked for
monsters these were guys no one else
would touch from places like Ukraine and
Zimbabwe and Neverland so what now a few
months ago Michael Cohen was sentenced
after that after this now Roger stone
looks like he's gonna go to jail they're
gonna have to run the re-election
campaign from inside so this seems like
it would have been a great week right
for the Democrats to make some political
hay but no of course they're Democrats
they spent the week arguing with each
other about whether one of their own
representative Alon Omar who has one fan
was anti-semitic only Democrats could
snatch the issue of anti-semitism away
from Republicans in fact Congressman
Steve King you know him of Iowa he said
today wait I thought we were the Jew
haters but this one all week they were
arguing about this it got so petty you
know some people were calling for
censure which is more drastic than a
resolution but not as severe as
expulsion but harsher than a reprimand
but worse than the silent treatment but
less degrading than finger wagging I
mean it was just so petty meanwhile
Trump did at least three things that
would get anybody else impeached this
week and among them insisting that his
kids have security clearance over the
objections of the CIA and the FBI
why do Trump's kids by the way get to
play a bigger role in our government
than the queen of England's kids you
know hookers just walk around holding
hands and wearing different hats they're
not in charge of the Middle East for
chrissakes Jared Kushner is called a
security threat by our own intelligence
agencies it's okay to hate him without
being anti-semitic right
also this week a project of our first
guest CPAC the conservative convention
it's kind of like the conservative
Oscars instead of when you get they
don't ask who are you wearing masks what
are you packing and it was notable this
week because Trump went on for two hours
and 20 minutes I mean there were kids
who were born at the beginning of the
speech who by the end of it were dating
are Kelly I mean you know what the me to
movement has finally caught up with the
music industry and it's about time they
have gotten to pass an assault like
nobody's business I mean one suite of an
allegation about an actor or a director
a conductor and their gun with musicians
everybody's like I'm gonna need to see a
12 part miniseries on this
you